make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and we are picking back up with the
immortal hulk we're getting back up
again i know we were kind of dropping
off from this
so this is one of those weird stories
not really even weird well it is weird
right it's immortal hulk like i don't
you know alewings immortal hulk is so
wonky but it's so cool at the same time
like it's so different from any other
incredible hulk story that i think i've
ever read in my entire life but this one
kind of picks up seemingly
in the middle of everything and what you
basically have here is this instance
where
something popped off and the incredible
hulk basically led off for immortal hulk
basically let off like this uh
this gamma explosion right basically
detonated like a gamma bomb and the
result is that no one really knows how
to handle it right all you really have
is rick jones
and you've got the incredible hulk and
so it's kind of like okay like
what's happening here now you do have
jackie for those of you guys who don't
remember
jackie's basically the friend of the the
immortal hulk she was a member of the
press and still kind of is but she's the
one who's kind of become an ally of the
hulk family which was kind of a way for
al ewing to have this situation or to
write these kind of stories where you
would at least have
some story out there that wouldn't shine
a negative light on the incredible hulk
or on the immortal hulk and kind of just
like show him as he is as opposed to how
the
the public generally perceives him
whether or not it's popular among the
public is something that alewing's never
particularly explored but it is kind of
cool to see
the important thing is that because of
all this gamma flight ultimately
responds right now gamma flight is by
all standards of measurement basically
an
anti-hulk force right i mean gamma
flight has had different histories and
different rosters over the course of
marvel comics but
in its current form like it has been
over the course the entire immortal hulk
run
it's an anti-hulk force and that's why
you have guys here who are some pretty
heavy hitters right you've got titania
who we've talked about in the original
secret war story from 1984 because she's
been around for so long he was basically
just a super strong chick you've got the
absorbing man crusher creel who was one
of the most criminally underrated
characters
in all of marvel comics really until
immortal hulk that's the reason why this
story is so
awesome for crusher creel it isn't an it
is a story that focuses on the hulk
right this is al ewing's hulk run
but he's done so much work to expand on
crusher creel that it's amazing and then
you have puck
i don't i never really understood why
puck was on this team
but you have puck right just this really
short guy but the the result here is
that of course they basically kind of go
after the incredible hulk with the
intention of taking him out now the
entirety
like like jackie yourself is like trying
to keep this from happening but at the
end of the day
gamma flight's main their their main
prerogative right their number one
goal here is to incapacitate the hulk to
essentially take the hulk out
and so in this conflict he basically
rips off the arm of crusher creel which
he's never going to lose his arm forever
right all he has to do is just bond
himself to metal and then his arm will
regrow or
any substance out there it doesn't
really matter titania gets pissed off
because her and crusher creel have been
banging for a long time
and so ultimately she goes after the
immortal hulk now while all that's
happening
jackie notices something jackie notices
that rick jones is smiling the whole
time now
one of the things that we learned in the
last video is that this is not actually
rick jones right rick jones is possessed
by the leader
by by samuel stearns one of the main
enemies of the immortal hulk but we
don't really
know how that happened right we don't
really know exactly how it is
that the leader managed to take control
and basically possess rick jones but
then you also have crusher creole who
comes with this this like amazing idea
right he's like okay he's like think
about at home slice he's like
you're the absorbing man you can absorb
and turn into essentially any material
out there
the one thing we've never seen him
absorb and turn into is adamantium i
guarantee we will
at some point along the line just
because of all the work that's being
done here but he's like i can absorb and
turn into anything and then he realizes
i can also do it with gamma radiation
right if it exists i can turn
into it and so literally he just absorbs
all this gamma radiation like he's done
before
and then just emerges as like this giant
huge mountain of a man
now from there we switch back over to
shadow base where the main hulk family
is kind of residing right doc sampson
and and so on
and then suddenly you have like
basically this guy del fry who's
currently sitting in a in a giant tank
now
del fry was a character we were
previously introduced to in the early
launch of
of immortal hulk right and it's been a
little while so kind of a refresher here
del fry was basically a kid who or
really a high school kid who was playing
football and his dad essentially
injected him with gamma radiation
under the idea that it would basically
enhance him a little bit but it would
prevent any of the major injuries that
he would likely sustain while playing
football right so
ligament tears broken bones different
things like that and it would give him
the best opportunity for success
the problem with this is that he died
like immediately right he died like
immediately when that happened
and so what ends up going on here is
that the the immortal hulk
and his and his allies had essentially
stumbled across this kind of gamma
radiation signal
and then came across the grave of del
fry dug him up and they've just kind of
been
i guess experimenting on him to a degree
or trying to get a better understanding
of him since they don't really know
anything about him but by and large he's
just kind of been in the background well
suddenly
he pops up right he just emerges like
literally emerges from his tank
disintegrates one of the one of the
scientists and then immediately goes
after the whole group now
one of the things that we find out here
kind of a little bit of a flashback is
that when you do get this origin
where he was exposed to gamma radiation
by his dad and then ultimately died
that the reality is the green door
opened behind him and instead of the one
below all passing through
it was the leader so somehow or another
the leader managed to find his way to
the realm of the one below all we'll
actually find out how that happened but
basically
del fry has been reliving the same
moment over and over and over again
uh that was essentially his death and so
the leader kind of steps in
and then basically possesses del fry and
that's how del fry is coming to life at
the moment right now the leader is
literally going through and just
attacking him right now initially
like leonard sampson like doc sampson
doesn't know who this
is right he's just he he just thinks
it's like you know del fry who's just
kind of popped up
and maybe like del fry's been listening
quote unquote that he wasn't actually
dead
right he was really alive the whole time
and just kind of in a form of stasis but
then as soon as his leader starts
talking about things like remember how i
made you who you are right because he's
the one that more or less made doc
sampson that the result is that doc
sampson realizes it's the leader
and that's when he kind of starts to
panic a little bit of course he ends up
going after him but the reality is
there's not much doc samson can do in
the face of the leader especially with
with a guy like this because he
immediately sees
samson and says okay now it's time to
play the game and then basically
snatches him and takes him to the below
place right to the realm of the one
below all with one below wall just kind
of resides there
and for the most part it's a little bit
of of you know some exposition
but not a whole lot here right instead
of it's more of just kind of playing
mind games
and it's basically saying that like you
know the leader has managed to reach the
realm
of the one below all by passing through
a green door and and
again not a whole lot there there's not
much in the way of explanation but one
of the things that he does kind of hit
on here
is he enter he introduces this idea of
what's called the red door
now again this is kind of a big deal and
the reason why is because if you guys
recall what's been going on with the
immortal hulk so far
that whenever a person who's exposed to
gamma radiation dies
that they basically end up being taken
to the realm of the one below all
there's this kind of connection that
exists between the one below all and
grammar radiation itself and it all kind
of goes back to the formation of the
hulk but the long and short of this is
that when a person with gamma radiation
dies quote unquote they go to the realm
of the one below all and a green door
opens which is basically a means for
them
to pass into the real world this is why
being possessed by the one below all is
such a big deal because if a person like
doc sampson were to arrive there and
then become possessed by the one below
all they could pass through the green
door and enter into the real world and
then have this
virtually non-omnipotent level of power
uh the result of this
is that with the door being changed to
red what it essentially means is that if
doc sampson were to pass through it what
it basically means is that either doc
sampson cannot pass through the red door
meaning he can't come back and that
seems to be the case because you know
the way that samuel stearns describes it
is he says red for danger red for stop
uh from this side at least so basically
mean that like no magic can return
him to life that he's basically stuck
here or the possibility exists that if
he does pass through the green door he
would actually die
and go on to the realm of mistress death
that more or less seems to be the case
we're not given an actual explanation
here all we really have to go by is
what you know the leader says which is
the red door means you can't pass
through it right it'd be like walking
into a wall you can't go back to the
realm of the living you're essentially
stuck here
the results of this is that the
incredible whole kind of going back to
immortal hulk facing off against
absorbing man
it's a cool bit of a conflict here it's
it's interesting right i mean you see
the immortal hulk literally fighting a
giant you know form of like
gamma energy but one of the things that
happens is that with the leader in
possession of both
rick jones as well as del fry when one
of them is talking
the other one is as well so you
literally have rick jones who's just
kind of
talking to somebody who's not there
because of the fact that del fry is
talking
to like the people who are there right
in the in the gamma base and so
ultimately charlene who again is kind of
the science like the head science group
of the the hulk family
ends up kind of initiating this
teleportation right there's this kind of
thing where she basically ends up
ripping del fry away uh literally like
translocating him
at the same time you end up having doc
sampson who basically cracks uh
the one below all version of the leader
over the head
and so what it does is it creates a kind
of energy effect right where basically
the leader
as he's in possession of del fry as well
as him being in possession of
rick jones kind of reflects this pain
right this anguish because if you
consider these guys to be like
facsimiles then the leader
as he exists in the realm of the one
below all right now is like the leader
prime right so it's like
if if the leader duplicated himself and
then you attacked the main leader
the other duplicates would feel the same
pain right i don't know if that really
makes any sense but that's basically
what's happening here and so ultimately
they're kind of teleported away
and then one of the things that kind of
goes on and this is all really kind of
the plan of the leader
the idea of counting on what gamma
flight would do with the incredible hulk
being pushed continually over and over
again
and the rest of the team being
distracted nobody really being there in
order to talk him down
jackie tries to but the leader knows
gamma flight and he knows the history of
the immortal hulk well enough to know
the gamma flight is not going to listen
right there their main
goal here is to destroy or at least to
to uh kill immortal hulk which is really
just kind of incapacitating them which
they're aware of and that nobody's
really going to bring this to uh to a
peaceful end and that's exactly what
happens gamma flight basically kills the
immortal hulk and then the immortal hulk
is teleported to the realm of the one
below all when the green door opens and
so again that's kind of his
his bit of a situation here now what you
also have is this really interesting
concept
where you have this being that's
effectively chained up right like
literally chained up in this giant
uh steel container and essentially held
there it kind of talks about how like
they can feel everything that's going on
right they can they can feel everything
taking place
it's kind of called the inner world
which is basically the mindscape of
bruce banner right inside the mind of
banner himself and that this individual
was essentially captured by the leader
and chained up in this location and
basically kept there right indicating
whoever this person is
their power is far beyond anything the
leader can really can really pull
off here right and so what you end up
getting is kind of the leader in the
form of world breaker hulk which is
pretty nuts and by all standards of
measurement we'd have to assume he
contains the same level of power as the
world breaker hulk does right otherwise
why give us this form of the leader why
would alewing make him look this way
and it's one of these things where again
the immortal hulk is kind of
experiencing these dreams or this kind
of
memory series in his mind and speaking
out right as he's experiencing that
right but ultimately
he's taken to where joe fix it and bruce
banner are chained up inside of banner's
own mindscape now this is kind of the
crazy thing and this is an important
thing to understand here when it comes
to the immortal hulk
i know it seems a little strange but
what's basically going on here is a
foreign entity has infiltrated the mind
of bruce banner and then in turn
is controlling it that's not uncommon
for the incredible hulk mythos not
insofar as some foreign entity taking
over the mind of banner but in the sense
of one of the personalities in banner's
mind essentially taking over all the
others right we've seen that happen
in different forms we've even seen these
personalities merge into a singular
personality which is
professor hulk right we've seen what
happens when these kind of things calm
down right when these kind of things
take place in in the incredible hulk's
mind and so basically joe fix it
is chained up here bruce banner is
chained up here and now the immortal
hulk is chained
up here and that the whole idea here of
the of the leader is to take bruce
banner and send him through the green
door
and into the realm of the one below all
why it is he's doing this again we don't
fully understand we'll find out here
here in a minute or two but in that
moment bruce banner cries out for help
right cries out for help from anybody
who will listen
and then in comes this guy who was
chained up who's basically revealed
to be the devil hulk now here's the
crazy thing about this
the devil hulk is one of the more
interesting concepts or interesting
versions of the incredible hulk marvel
comics but you don't really see a whole
lot about it the way it's kind of given
to us here
because the mindscape is one of these
things where the personifications of the
different versions of the hulk are
directly tied to the emotional state of
the immortal hulk and really just the
experiences of banner over the course of
his life that the devil hulk in a lot of
ways represents all the torment and
suffering he's experienced
over the course of his life kind of
manifested um in a lot of ways it's
almost given to us as this idea that the
devil hulk was the first version of the
hulk to manifest in the mind of banner
when he was being abused by his father
and then once he actually was exposed to
gamma radiation because of the gamma
bomb the incredible hulk manifested then
you got things like joe fix it and so on
and so forth
but the devil hulk is the most
emotionally powerful of all the all the
versions of the hulk that exist out
there
and so that's why you essentially see
this kind of fight breaking down
between uh what is basically world
breaker hulk uh who's more or less
possessed by the leader
and then devil hulk and devil hulk
literally crushes world breaker hulk i
mean just
pummels this guy absolutely pummels this
guy
it's not even close right because it's
just sheer
raw emotion here and that's one of the
big differences is that with world
breaker hulk
it was technically the incredible hulk
at his angriest but he had also achieved
this just kind of
pure form right in the sense that it
seemed like the incredible hulk at his
angriest but also his most calm at the
same time and i know it sounds like an
oxymoron to say that but that's why like
when you go and you read
you know world breaker or world war hulk
by by uh greg pack
that the the world breaker hulk is
basically like i wouldn't really say
like
peaceful but he's methodical like it's
just one of these things where it's like
okay like i'm so pissed off that i'm
rational now
and that's like a whole nother level of
being angry but uh but nonetheless you
know it's one of these one of these kind
of crazy things here
where you basically switch over to the
leader and we kind of find out how all
this popped off with him now the idea
behind this is that those individuals
who
are able to access the realm of the one
below all through gamma radiation
that it is most usually only allowed by
those individuals who are of pure gamma
radiation right meaning that they are
rooted in the incredible hulk and the
gamma radiation he contains
the leader is a little bit different
here the way is explained here
is that the leader essentially
synthesized a means by which to enter to
basically create a green door and
enter the realm of the one below all but
when he got there he met brian banner
and one of the things about this
is that brian banner kind of depicts
this idea that when he was doing all
these crappy things and when he was
kind of kind of tormenting the the
immortal hulk you know during
at the beginning of al ewing's immortal
hulk run that is because he was
possessed by the one below all which we
know
we know that was the case right we know
that to be the case but one of the
things that
that leader doesn't really understand is
what is that
the one below all is looking for right
and how is it that a person
can kind of reach into the real world
and then manipulate
the immortal hulk from here because the
leader wants to just destroy
he's always wanted to destroy the
immortal right that's kind of his main
goal and that was all that's
you know as basic as that ideology is
here the way he goes about it is genius
given the fact that the way that brian
banner explains it the one below all
needs a physical body that the one below
all doesn't actually have a physical
form itself instead
it's just raw desire and exceedingly
terrible desires right but it's just
more or less raw emotion what it needs
to do is
bond itself to a host and then in turn
use that host to enter into the real
world that the one below all in its
current form cannot pass through a green
door
and then just enter into the real world
and then just take on some kind of a
physical form and conquer all of the
multiverse it doesn't work that way and
so that's when
when leader realizes i can get behind
this and so literally leader basically
tricks brian banner and then completely
absorbs him and so the idea is that in
some of these instances when brian
banner appeared in the immortal hulk run
that it was actually the leader in
possession or appearing to look like
brian banner not only that now that he's
consumed brian he has what's called the
mark of the one below all and then in
turn he reveals his goal is to actually
achieve a means by which the one below
all can enter into the real world
and then conquer all of reality kind of
hearkening back to the story that we did
where the immortal hulk was on a cosmic
level
and basically destroyed the entirety of
the multiverse when the multiverse is
reborn
in its ninth iteration um that basically
leader realizes the
only way for the one below all to
achieve its full totality of power
is if it is in possession of the
immortal hole and that's the whole goal
behind this that that the leader wants
to help the one below all succeed the
only way to do that
is to mess with uh to basically end up
snatching the immortal hulk and banner
bring them to the realm of the one below
all and then allow the one below all to
essentially possess them
and then go into the multiverse and
destroy everything in existence right he
literally wants to help the end of
creation and so again kind of jumping
back to the current moment
that when you have the devil hulk just
absolutely pummeling immortal hulk
the big fear that kind of pops up here
is you end up having the arrival of the
leader
manifest into the form of brian banner
now it's not one of these things
where it terrifies the devil hulk to the
point where he starts crying or anything
like that but the devil hulk was born
out of the abuse of brian banner and
really in a lot of ways it's part and
parcel
to brian banner and so that's when he's
kind of like like where do you think
like all this rage and everything that
you are
you are me right you you are my rage
incarnate right you're my
wrath you're you're a reflection of me
and as abusive as i was where do you
think you got your personality from how
do you think you became
the person that you are you know where
is the lie in all of this right if you
tell me that that i'm not you
you know or you're not me and that i'm
lying to you where's the lie look at
yourself look at me right look at the
abuse that i put you through and look at
who you are
look at the things that you've done
right you are a reflection of me and
bruce banner kind of refuses to accept
that and then immediately goes after the
leader now of course this leads to the
immortal hulk kind of watching
all this unfold and desiring to kind of
end the conflict right and it's not
because of the fact that he doesn't want
want to fight for the sake of wanting a
fight it's because of the fact that in
seeing brian banner's persona
the immortal hulk are really kind of i
guess is really just the baseline
incredible hulk at this point
is not the sharpest tool in the shed and
so ultimately he kind of comes to this
idea that all i want my father to do is
tell me that he loves me right that's
the only thing that i want i just want
my dad to say like
like i love you i love you i care about
you and in doing this he
stops the devil hulk from destroying the
leader who he's kind of seeing as brian
banner and because of the fact that
brian banner is absorb has been absorbed
by the leader so to destroy the leader
is to destroy brian banner and to
destroy brian banner
is to ruin the immortal hulk's chances
of getting his father's approval and his
father's love
and so in that moment it basically
allows the leader to kill the devil hulk
right to basically decapitate him and
that was their one shot at success there
was their one shot to come out on top
there's no real conceivable way for them
to win anymore and so what you have is
the leader who snatches up bruce banner
takes him through the green door and
disappears and all you're left with
is basically the hulk and joe fix it and
joe fixit is
pissed right joe fixit is mad as hell
because he's kind of like okay
this is a problem right like this is a
major issue like why would you do this
right why why would you do any of this
like you've literally just destroyed our
chances of saving banner
and quite possibly doomed all of
creation right and so from there you end
up jumping to the to the
the base of gamma flight right to really
the alpha flight space station but you
end up jumping to the to the gamma
flight team
and you have of course walter also known
as sasquatch who's still dead after
being shot in the head who's just kind
of in a in a kind of
not really i guess a coffin and that's
what you want to call it but basically
he ends up popping back to life right
now you also have jackie who kind of
introduces this idea that where gamma
flight's operating under the guys that
like the immortal hulk just for whatever
reason went crazy and destroyed an
entire town in a gamma explosion her
response is it doesn't actually seem to
be that way
right that that the immortal hulk was
pissed off like exceedingly mad for a
second or two
and then calmed down due to whatever it
was that was going on and then rick
jones showed up
and rick jones touched him and then
something happened and then
like literally the immortal hulk just
snapped and just let off this massive
explosion
and so looking at the facts because of
the fact that you know she's a
journalist her job will ideally her job
is to look at the facts that she kind of
looks at this and says from what i can
tell
rick jones was the one who caused this
right and that's when you basically have
leonard sampson who is kind of the new
sasquatch took over the body of
of walter and then just kind of popped
back up again and says yeah basically it
was rick jones that caused all of this
how he caused it and why he caused it i
don't fully know but we know that he did
and so during this time of course while
the the immortal hulk has kind of held
kind of put in a holding facility
because again he's more or less immortal
right in the sense that like he'll
always heal and the the injury he
sustained didn't really kill him
his body would more or less heal and
come back that he's met by the arrival
of henry peter guyrick now henry peter
geirk is
old school this guy is og og technically
he is the head of the alpha flight
program right now
but for those of you guys who who aren't
really familiar with this history this
is the guy who helped the spearhead
project wide awake the sentinels against
the x-men and all that kind of stuff
that was henry peter guyer right this
guy is og right i mean this guy has
worked against the superhero community
in almost every conceivable way
since he's been introduced in marvel
comics right if you're a superhero team
that exists out there
there's a good chance you've had a run
in with henry peter geyrick and so
basically he's kind of held here now one
of the the reason why i include this
little tidbit here
because normally i would have skipped
over it but the reason why we included
this little tidbit here is you have this
moment where again
like everything that henry peter geyrick
says kind of echoes so to speak through
the mindscape of of banner so
essentially
joefixit hears everything that henry
peter guyrick is saying and one of the
things that gyrik says
is that you can't escape your bonds
right if you decide to turn back into
banner and shrink down into your current
form
your your human form which of course we
know he can't do that the bonds will
shrink with him and that's when it hits
on joe fix it oh i know exactly what to
do right like
apparently this guy hasn't kept up on
things we don't just shrink down back
into our human forms anymore our human
forms
bust out of our physical forms right
just literally emerge from which leads
me to believe
there have to be like these these
immortal hulk corpses all
over the world we're banner where
instead of like the immortal hulk quote
unquote
shrinking back down into banner then
instead banner just like busts out of
his immortal hook form and that's how
banner returns to normal but that's what
it hits on on joe fixing who's kind of
like like okay
we can escape this so literally he busts
out of the form of the immortal hulk
right which is how he returns to his
normal self and then takes out henry
peter garrick and the two guards
grabs a gun and then basically starts to
leave now of course he runs into samson
and the rest of gamma flight
and uh and samson realizes okay this is
joe fix it right this is one of bruce
banner's alternate personalities that's
why he looks like banner because it's
just one of his other personalities that
exists but like joe fix is not as crazy
as he used to be right which for any of
you guys who know
the history of joe fixed in marvel
comics this guy used to be intense right
like joe fix it i still say joe fix it
personality wise is the best version of
the hulk who's out there
i loved joe fix it he was so cool and he
was so fun he was literally like
literally the guy ran vegas at one point
so it was just kind of like damn like
this is awesome his personality is
amazing
in any event uh where where samson's
kind of like yeah you know joe fix it
he's a he's a lot more reasonable than
he used to be he's like yeah that's me
all over
reasonable and then fires a gun into the
window of the space station right
it gets sucked out into space now the
protocols immediately kick in right
which just
starts shutting down you know shuts down
this access hole but like literally joe
fix it's
ripped into the vacuum of space now you
would normally expect that to kill him
it doesn't because again like he turns
back into the immortal hulk and it's a
genius strategy there
right emerge from the immortal hulk into
your human form in order to escape your
confines
jump into space the danger of the
situation will just force them to turn
back into the immortal hulk and that's
exactly what happens
ultimately he ends up landing on the
coney island channel the problem is that
when he gets there he's immediately met
by the thing ben grimm which you guys
had to know it was only a matter of time
before we saw this conflict unfold but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like
and yeah i will catch you all later
peace
hey
so
you